Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain the 2018 Rom-Com film
called “I’m Not An Easy Man.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Damien is a shameless chauvinist, who works
for a male dominated marketing agency.
He proudly uses all the benefits of living in
a patriarchal world to his advantage. He likes
dominating women he meets and treats them like
objects for his pleasure. Damien's boss Marco
loves him and always gives him the important
projects and assignments. He has a close friend
and neighbour named Christophe Lamy who’s a famous
writer. One day, during Chris’s new book’s launch,
Damien meets his new attractive assistant
Alexandra. He is dating a woman named Sybille
but that doesn’t stop him from flirting
with other women. He hits on Alexandra but
she finds his chauvinist attitude off putting
and turns him down. When Chris’s pregnant wife
Lolo arrives with their two children, Damien and
Sybille ask her if they can come over for dinner
to celebrate Chris’s book launch. However, Lolo is
in a bad mood and she turns them down, saying she
can’t have guests over on a school night. Damien
and Chris quickly realise that Lolo is upset
because Chris forgot her birthday again. After
Lolo leaves with the children, the two friends go
out to buy flowers for her. Like his typical self,
Damien makes passes at random girls on the street.
While whistling at a girl, Damien gets
distracted and hits his head on an electric pole,
knocking himself unconscious. When he opens his
eyes, he finds a female medic tending to him.
After collecting himself, Damien meets
Sybille and Lolo, who are going out together.
The latter asks Chris to take care of the
children before departing. On the way back home,
Damien complains about feeling cold and says
he feels that his jeans are too tight. Chris
speculates it could be because of his sagging
balls and suggests that he should get a cosmetic
procedure to fix it. Damien laughs off the
suggestion, thinking it’s a joke but little
does he know that Chris is dead serious.
Back at his apartment, Damien puts on a warm
muffler and a packet of cold peas on his
head. He watches TV to entertain himself
but for some reason he sees that every show
on TV is objectifying men instead of women.
The next morning, Damien wakes up and proceeds
to get ready for work but to his astonishment,
he only finds short and bright colored clothes
in his closet. He puts on a grey sweatpant,
tight white t-shirt and heads to work.
At work, he notices that most of the
employees are now women, who make inappropriate
comments about his body and appearance. Damien’s
coworker Sophie takes him to her office and tells
him that the company didn’t choose his project.
She calls his humour delicate and tells him that
the clients want more feminine and crude humour
therefore a female employee got the gig. Damien is
surprised and asks to speak with Marcus. However,
when Marco arrives, Damien is stunned to
see him serving coffee. Damien flips out
and tells Sophie that she is making a big mistake
by not selecting his project. Enraged, Sophie
tells him to calm his hormones before firing him.
Puzzled and confused, Damien goes to a bar where
he notices two men wearing veils. He freaks out
and runs to his parents' eatery. There he sees
his mom mincing the meat as his dad entertains the
customers. Upon seeing Damien, his father starts
bothering him about settling down while his mother
comes to his defense. The world seems to have
turned upside down. Freaked out, Damien goes back
to the electric pole from earlier in the movie
and bangs his head on it, hoping to teleport
back to the old world but without success.
That night, he meets Sybille for drinks. At the
bar, Sybille orders a beer instead of champagne
and scantily clad men entertain the patrons
but Damien seems to have started to wrap his
head around this new world. Sybille then goes
to Damien’s apartment to have intercourse but
she is put off by his hairy chest and storms out.
Damien shares his work dilemma with Chris and Lolo
who advise him to seek help of a masculist group
that fights discrimination against men at work.
Lolo suddenly goes into labour and she is rushed
to a hospital, where she gives birth to a baby
while hanging by a bar. Chris’s boss, who is
revealed to be Alexandra, isn't happy that he is
taking a paternity leave. However, Chris promises
her to find someone to take his place and an out
of work Damien jumps at the opportunity.
Before sending Damien to work for Alex,
Chris gives Damien a makeover. He cuts his
hair, threads his eyebrows, shaves his armpits,
chest hair and also the hair down below. A booty
shorts wearing Damien then goes to work for Alex,
who is a dominant seductress and successful
writer. Alex lives in a fancy house and she
seems to be fond of collecting marbles. When
she sees Damien, she notes that he is tall and
makes him make coffee for her. She then gives
him a list of things to do before heading out.
Damein meets her housekeeper Martel who showers
praise for her and says only women can write
good novels, which offends Damein.
After doing menial jobs all day,
Damein gets fed up and when Alex returns, he tells
her that he is not cut for this job and world.
When he tells her that he can’t live in a world
where women dictate what he does, Alex tells him
to save his masculist rant for someone else.
For comfort, he calls Sybille to have
intercourse but only for her to leave him
disappointed when she finishes before making
him climax. Fed up of the matriarchal world,
Damien and Chris join a masculist group called
“Tit for tat”. The group is known for wearing fake
boobs and organising protests against matriarchy.
Meanwhile, it strikes Alex that a
masculist character for her new book
could be revolutionary, and she starts writing
her book using Damien as an inspiration.
Damien receives a text message from Alex and
decides to meet her after his father keeps
pressuring him to settle down. At the bar, Alex
tells him that the world he keeps talking about
is interesting. She says that it is not so
bad for women as they receive gifts and have
men hold doors open for them. Excited,
Damien enthusiastically tells her about
the patriarchal world over drinks. After
having a few too many drinks in his system,
Damien tries to make out with Alex but she tells
him that she doesn’t take advantage of drunk guys
and sends him back home in a cab.
It is revealed that Alex had recorded
her conversation with Damien, which she
takes to her boss Annie Meyer the next day.
Alex tells her that she wants to show the world
that even masculists are dependent on women. She
plans to get Damien to fall in love with her so
she can eventually break his heart and teach him
a lesson. Annie loves the idea and asks to see the
writing sample on her desk as soon as possible.
As Alex continues to court Damien, he tells Chris
that he can no longer work for Alex because he is
dating her. This upsets Chris because he
is afraid that he won’t get his job back
after his paternity leave ends. The two get
into an argument and Damien brings up the fact
that his wife doesn’t respect him. Upset,
Chris tells Damien to never talk to him.
Alex and Damien spend more and more time together
and eventually have intercourse. Unbeknownst to
Damien, she even records them having it. Alex
takes him to her work parties and even introduces
him to Annie. During their time together, Alex
continues to have intercourse with other men,
one of whom vandalises her home for using
him. Meanwhile, blinded by love, Damien
irons her shirt and runs errands for her. Chris
eventually forgives Damien. When Chris tells him
about Lolo’s unfaithfulness, Damien comforts him
and promises to be by his side no matter what.
Meanwhile, Alex always makes it a point to hide
her writing samples from Damien which only makes
him more curious. He asks to see it but she
changes the topic and asks him to work for her.
Damein turns down the offer, saying he’s
applied to work at a bar because he doesn't
want to be dependent on her. He says he wants
to be equal to her, which irritates her.
One day, a man named Daffodil shows up at
Alex’s place unannounced while she is away.
Daffodil seems upset and forces his way into
Alex’s bedroom. Worried, Damien texts Alex,
who tells him to call the cops on him. Daffodil
spray paints “small tits” on her bedroom wall
and tells Damien that the marbles on her
shelf represent her each male conquest.
A tearful Daffodil tells him that
she made him feel smart and worthy
only to make him feel like a fool in the
end. Damien is taken aback by the revelations
and he confronts Alex about the marbles. He asks
her if he is also just another marble for her.
Alex refuses to take responsibility and gaslights
him instead. An upset Damien then leaves.
Damien starts seeing a therapist. Meanwhile,
Alex submits her first sample to her publisher,
who loves it and tells her she can’t wait to read
the rest. However, Alex has started to have doubts
about the novel as she feels it's cruel. She
suggests new novel ideas to Annie but the latter
turns them down and orders her to finish the
rest of her novel. After a lot of deliberation,
Alex decides against writing the novel
and tells her decision to Annie.
Meanwhile, Chris kicks Lolo out of the
house and she crashes at Damien’s apartment.
Lolo reveals that she cheated on Chris while she
was pregnant and her hormones were raging. She
regrets cheating on him and asks Damien
to convince Chris to take her back.
Alex makes amends and returns back to
Damien’s life. He doesn’t waste time
in proposing marriage to her and to his
astonishment, she accepts the proposal.
Damien and his father convince Chris to forgive
Lolo. Damien also tells his father about Alex.
The next day, Damien and Chris join the masculist
group ‘Tit for tat' in protesting against
a French college for only honoring female
writers. At the venue, Damien meets Annie,
who recognises him. When Annie smugly asks him
if he has nothing better going on in his life,
Chris proudly tells her that Damien is actually
getting married to Alex. Damien taunts her,
saying some women are more open-minded than
others. However, Annie snatches the smile and
pride out of his face when she tells him that Alex
is already married. Stunned by the revelation,
Damien rushes to confront Alex. When he finds
her door locked, Damien tricks Martel into
giving him the keys to her apartment. After
gaining entry into her home, Damien goes
through her belongings and finds her marriage
certificate. Hurt, he trashes her room.
Meanwhile, Alex is at her husband’s place to pick
up her daughter. Before departing, Alex tells him
that she has filed for divorce and this time
he must sign the papers. Alex then returns home
with her daughter and she learns from Martel that
Damien had dropped by. When she enters her home,
she finds the entire place trashed. Alex notices
her writing samples on the floor and realises
that Damien has found out about the novel.
A worried Alex looks for Damien everywhere.
Meanwhile, Chris gets a call from his friend Erica
who tells him that Damien is drunk out of his mind
at her bar and some girls are harassing him.
Lolo and Chris then proceed to rush to the bar.
Outside their apartment, they meet Alex and tell
her about Damien. Alex follows them to the bar,
where an old woman is trying rape a drunk Damien.
Lolo fends off the old woman’s friends while Alex
finds the old woman knocked unconscious on the
ground. Worried, she rushes by Damien’s side
but he pushes her away. Alex admits her
mistake and comes clean about the novel
and the recordings. But this makes Damien even
more upset because he only found out about the
marriage and not the novel and recordings. Feeling
cheated, Damien slaps her. Alex tries to explain
herself but the two accidentally head butt
each other and knock themselves unconscious.
Alex then wakes up in an ambulance being tended
to by male medics. She rushes out of the ambulance
and notices that she is in a patriarchal
world. The streets are filled with raunchy
advertisements that objectify women. The movie
ends as she notices a feminist march and among its
participants is Damien who calls out for her.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.